there is
a major racial racist hate crime
incident
at a catholic high school in rochester
according to the newspapers
you see according to the newspapers
there was a graffiti incident
at our lady of mercy school for young
women last week
someone graffitied the n-word
on
a bathroom wall
and on the back it said this school is
filled with a bunch of n-words
not the words you know the people
get out
or else
and then man there were protests outside
of this school
people were furious and what happened
you already know what i don't even need
to tell you the conclusion of this story
sensible people people with two brain
cells to rub together who have not been
completely brainwashed by ideology will
look at that headline
they'll say oh it was a hoax
how dare you are you telling me racism
doesn't exist pretty much yeah i mean
you know the human heart is evil from
its beginning but
beyond that base level of original sin
in a fallen world yeah racism is fake it
doesn't exist the only legal racism is
against whites and asians in affirmative
action and that sort of legal
discrimination but if you're telling me
that this is a country run by klansmen
where lynchings are commonplace or exist
at all where crosses are burning on
lawns i'm going to tell you you're a
complete lunatic and none of that is
happening whatsoever and so when we see
these alleged incidents we just know 999
999 times out of a million they're going
to be fake and guess what happened guess
what happened
a student confessed to writing the
message
the student is remaining anonymous
she's being protected because she's a
minor
but according to all of the reports
it's a black student
we cover these shows we cover cover
these incidents all the time i have a
chapter of my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
number one national bestseller dedicated
to incidents such as this
why do these incidents happen
i don't think it happens necessarily
because these kids are malicious maybe
they are they might be malicious but
more i think they're deluded
i think they're trying to resolve a sort
of cognitive dissonance
they are told
that they live in a culture
that hates black people where whitey
where the patriarchy where the man keeps
them down and where as lebron james says
a black person can't walk outside in
america without being hunted down so
that's what they're told that's what
they're taught
from their earliest ages
that's what all students are taught
and then
the reality does not conform to that
delusion
and so what do they do
do they change their delusions and
opinions
no they try to change reality
they go in and they say oh well huh i'm
not see people aren't taking racism
seriously here because there isn't any
of it so i know what i'll do i'll lie
i'll write i'll i'll create a hoax of a
racist incident and you know it won't be
honest in this case
but that lie will get to a greater truth
because i know because of my ideology i
know that these incidents are happening
all over the country and it's merely my
misfortune that they're not happening at
this school so i could show everybody
how horrible and racist america really
is so i'm just gonna
you know i'm gonna get the ball rolling
a little bit and just write this in and
that'll show this lie will show them the
truth
of course it doesn't because all of
these incidents that are allegedly
happening that are forming their
worldview
are
hoaxes i
you see it really most clearly in our
woman of the year according to usa today
the delusion says i am a woman
but the mirror says i am a man. the
reality says i am a man so what are you
going to do are you going to change your
disordered thinking are you going to
change your fantasy to bring it in line
with reality it would seem like that's
the easiest thing to do it's a lot
cheaper and less painful than undergoing
surgeries
no we're going to try to change reality
that is the power of ideology
you see it working on
young girls at a catholic school in
rochester
you see it working on grown men
who are somehow the assistant secretary
of health right now go to ring.com
knowles you know about ring's video
doorbell i've told you about it for
years you know about ring alarm i've
even mentioned ring alarm this
award-winning security system with
available professional monitoring when
you subscribe
amazing system where you can easily
install it yourself well
you might not know that recently i've
gone pro
i have gone pro with ring alarm pro ring
alarm pro
is just the next level it is the top
shelf cnet calls ring alarm pro a giant
leap for home security after using it
you're going to see exactly what we're
talking about ring alarm pro helps
protect the entire home and the wi-fi it
runs on with ring alarm pro ring
combined a home security system and a
wi-fi router
so it protects your home and your
network your physical world your virtual
world
i i can't recommend this enough i love
ring it makes me feel more secure now it
makes me feel more secure digitally as
well as physically for my family when
i'm on the road when we're all on the
road protects the home from freeze fire
flood it's just tremendous go learn more
at ring.com
knowles do not wait ring.com
knowles
i'm so glad you like that clip now
please please i implore you ring the
bell subscribe get the notifications for
every video we put out best thing you
can do is go over to apple podcasts or
stitcher or spotify or wherever you get
your podcasts and subscribe to the
michael knowles show leave a five star
review if you wouldn't mind
and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you